en este vídeo vamos a ponerle ojos a
beats y tenemos estos leds de colores y
tapas de refrescos elegimos una broca
que sea del mismo diámetro que el led ya
que queremos perforar un agujero del
tamaño del led en el centro de la tapa
rosca nuestro led será nuestra pupila y
la tapa rosca será el iris usamos
nuestro cutter para limpiar el borde del
agujero y retirar el exceso que queda
ponemos el led en el agujero y ya
tenemos un ojo para nuestra bici
el left tiene cuatro patitas y la más
larga es la positiva lo cual es
importante ya que queremos cablear el
led con la polaridad correcta vamos a
colocar dos leds en nuestra tarjeta de
prototipos en el lado de la extrema
izquierda y vamos a colocar tres
transistores estos transistores son los
mismos transistores nn que usamos en
nuestro módulo de sonido y en nuestra
cámara para poder encenderla y apagarla
estos leds usarán colores rojo azul y
verde los usaremos en el lado izquierdo
y derecho usamos resistencias de un kilo
en la base de nuestro transistor que es
la patita del centro ahora estamos
moviendo los cables para nuestro sensor
infrarrojo para poder tener más espacio
ponemos otra resistencia de un kilo en
la base de nuestro transistor ya que lo
colocamos vemos nuestro diagrama de
cableado y vemos que a uno es el led
verde a cero es el led rojo y el a2 es
el led azul vamos a asegurarnos de
cablear los leds de acuerdo con nuestro
diagrama para poder encender el color
correcto cuando queramos usamos el cable
verde para el led verde y lo conectamos
al transistor que controla el led verde
y el cable rojo al del rojo y el
transistor que enciende y apaga este led
rojo usamos el cable negro para el
transistor que enciende y apaga el led
azul ya que no tengo un cable azul y
podemos ver como estos están conectados
a las resistencias de un kilo aquí
tenemos una resistencia de 220 oms que
vamos a conectar a la patita central o
la patita más larga de nuestro led o de
ambos leds debería decir
esto es para evitar que los leds reciban
demasiada corriente y se quemen pueden
cambiar el valor de la resistencia y en
otro vídeo veremos cómo calcular el
valor correcto de la resistencia ya que
dependiendo de este valor tendremos
variaciones en la intensidad de la luz
del led
si usan una resistencia de mayor valor
la luz del led será más baja y si usan
una resistencia de menor valor la luz
del led será más brillante ya colocamos
estas dos en su lugar si se nos
dificulta insertar alguna de las patitas
hasta el fondo nos podemos apoyar de
nuestras pinzas de nariz de aguja ahora
ponemos nuestro cable rojo desde nuestro
circuito provisional desde la terminal
positiva que está abajo es una tarjeta
que colocamos en un vídeo anterior y lo
colocamos en el mismo renglón que el de
nuestra resistencia de 220 11 y
conectamos uno para cada led 1 del lado
derecho y el otro del lado izquierdo y
conectamos otro
conectamos el cable en el lado derecho
de la otra resistencia de 220 ohms la
hacemos un poco al lado para alimentar
el lado positivo y ahora necesitamos
conectar nuestro cable de tierra desde
el circuito provisional que distribuye
energía que se encuentra abajo hasta
nuestro led que se encuentra hasta la
extrema izquierda y lo ponemos en la
patita izquierda del transistor del lado
derecho
este es nuestro transistor que va a
encender el led verde ponemos otro cable
a tierra que va desde nuestro arduino
que tiene una conexión a tierra hasta
nuestro transistor de este lado ahora
vamos a distribuir otro cable de tierra
desde el lado izquierdo del transistor
que se encuentra a la izquierda hasta el
de en medio estamos usando el mismo
cableado que hicimos cuando ensamblamos
el módulo de sonido y cámara
ahora vamos a conectar la resistencia
que controla a leds rojo con él
del del rojo que está a la extrema
izquierda del led que vemos aquí
jakab leamos el verde como pueden ver
aquí abajo que se conecta con el cable
que está a la extrema derecha de este
mismo led
ahora vamos a colocar el cable para
nuestro led azul que es el que está
junto al verde pelamos el extremo del
cable y luego conectamos en el
transistor que lo enciende y apaga
ya he escrito un código para esto bueno
creo que descargamos un código para esto
un código de muestra que hace que el led
parpadee y cambie de color ustedes
pueden descargar este código de la
página web de arduino es para que
parpadee el efe debemos asegurarnos de
que está configurado para las conexiones
correctas que nosotros determinamos aquí
esto funciona así que ahora conectamos
este led con el que se encuentra del
otro lado tomamos nuestro cable verde y
lo ponemos en la misma patita del led
del otro lado pueden ver que ahora solo
se enciende el leds verde y no encienden
ni el led rojo en el azul porque no
hemos conectado el cable del led rojo y
del led azul enciende el rojo azul y
verde una y otra vez mientras que el
otro sólo enciende el verde ahora vamos
a colocar nuestros otros cables para
controlar los leds rojo y azul para que
ambos ojos parpadean en sincronía y
en este momento vamos a colocar el cable
rojo y veremos que comenzará a
encenderse el led rojo de manera que
veremos parpadear rojo y verde en lugar
de ver solo el verde justo ahora lo
pueden ver pero aún nos falta el azul
voy a dejar que observen esto un momento
para que vean que falta el parpadeo azul
del lado derecho el ojo de la izquierda
parpadea en rojo verde y azul y el de la
derecha solo en rojo y verde
ahora conectamos nuestro cable final y
esto nos permitirá encender rojo verde y
azul
algo que quiero que noten es que el led
azul no es tan brillante como el rojo y
el verde y ustedes pueden cambiar esto
al colocar una resistencia en cada led
en lugar de poner uno en la salida
positiva pueden poner en cada uno una
resistencia de valor diferente y hacer
que el azul sea más brillante o el verde
y el rojo menos brillantes como ustedes
quieran para que el brillo de todos sea
el mismo otra cosa que pueden ver es que
cuando la golpeó las luces se apagan
esta es una configuración temporal en
nuestra tarjeta de prototipos y es
posible que algo se desconecte así que
debemos tener cuidado de que esto no
ocurra pero al mismo tiempo esto nos da
la flexibilidad de poder cambiar la
configuración si así lo deseamos